I have to ask you
about Interstellar
so I think it's an incredible film I've
seen it Inspire so many scientists and
Engineers it's just uh philosopher
everybody humans it explores space
travel physics of space-time
human nature Human Condition human
connection
um how is that film expanded your
understanding of
uh the the universe and our place in it
yeah
well
it's the uh
it's got the old Mr Mayor on the corner
how big is that cloud
metaphor in it because that was
the character I played Cooper's that was
the existential question for him
head down practical stay here be a
father to my children
but it's dream
before his children were to go explore
space so when he's taking that
truck out and the countdown's going down
that's the the hinge of the existential
question that we all face in some form
um
the
the the the the sense of time I wish I
think everyone loves that sense of where
time can run at different speeds and I
there's a incredible scene where
Cooper is a father's
kidding video feed from his children who
aged and he's realizing he's missed all
that
[Laughter]
yeah
that it
you know I mean overall that that
concept makes me
consider and imagine
I'm gonna talk about mystical successes
instead of engineered ones like the
engineered ones that there's there's
ethos from that film and and what Nolan
put into that film and theories that
make me go
yeah what is it in this matter what do
we
maybe we are maybe we're it makes me go
maybe this is all it's already all been
it's already all been written what's
happening right now in this blip of time
you're here 53 years so far we'll see
how many we get
um
what other parallel timelines are
happening out there do is it is it
small-minded of us to Define
life on other planets as only something
that can live within a climate that has
water in this amount of o2 those terms
may be
um too too small thing what do you mean
who are we saying only life has to have
water in this amount of oxygen and
carbon dioxide I don't know maybe that's
maybe there's a whole redefinition of
the ingredients that other life forms
need
um
it's sure in a similar way to contact
this is a movie I did with Bob zimekus
um
inspires me that the universe is more
active and Lively and God's backyard's
bigger than I thought and wow that's
exciting
and you know people go now yeah you
believe in extraterrestrial life I said
yes man I think it'd be arrogant not to
I sure hope so you think there's alien
civilizations all out there intelligent
ones just far in far on the distant
Stars I
I hope so and I think we it's possible
may have many
Among Us right here
one and I go for the the Y naught in
that just to keep that that train of
thought open to the to learn and and and
and and and consider
you know those existential questions I
think be arrogant not to there's so many
hundreds of billions of planets just in
our galaxy just in ours I can't imagine
there's not life out there
and um
but I suspect it's very different like
you said than we are and we have to have
a humility to open our eyes to how
different life could be
and if and when we cross it
unlike we've had tendency to do when we
try to go with some
Nation takeovers
um
I think
it would be are inherent
glitch
to go in
believing that any other life-form
civilization wants to take over
territories to go into it with thinking
that okay this is an opposition
I I mean I I think that's a human trait
of ours
and to consider that another life
form would have an interest
that more land or more territory
is good for them I think is the thing is
this shallow idea I don't think they're
I think of it more like you know when I
think of Heaven those considerations are
not
in in anyone's mind heart or
intent in the heaven that I think of you
know so in other civilizations these
things I don't I mean I
I hope that if we would just see and
learn that would be the natural side of
welcoming it wouldn't be a primate
response to no I have fire and you're
coming over trying to put it out or I
have food and you're trying to steal my
food I don't I don't think it would be
I think it's a shallow thought to think
that oh it's going to be about ownership
and we would be trespassing I think it
would be I don't think they're
would have a sense of borders as we do I
just hope we humans are smart enough to
detect and to see aliens
because because of how different they
are you know we don't we often have a
very narrow definition of what is
intelligence you know it's very possible
that trees are extremely intelligent if
we kind of zoom out at a different time
scale a different like just look at
stuff in a from a bigger perspective
that that's outside of being so
human-centric it's great
quote that someone told me this
astrophysicist told me this how accurate
is or not someone else can argue the
validity of what I'm about to say or not
but I thought it really was a
prospective grabber for me like look see
the universe was created at midnight
humans came around at 11 59 and 36
seconds
I love little now these are that put
that frame like that make oh yeah the
pale blue dot there it is that
perspective something so relaxing and
empowering about that
at the same time and humbling
but confidence boosting yeah you know
allows forgiveness allows ambition
um I just love the perspective of that
that picture to picture it that way in
our timeline